well these guys be invited to the
wedding I can't afford them awkward
apparently Katy Perry is keeping things
tight when it comes to her upcoming
wedding to Orlando Bloom good this is
your way of saying they are actually not
invited yeah we know what we're doing
this all went down when Katy and her
fellow American Idol judges dropped by
Wednesday night's Jimmy Kimmel Live and
when I tell ya it only gets more
uncomfortable well it does waddle now
we've been dropping hints and a little
well where's it gonna be you don't need
to drop anymore no not invited just say
don't save the date they're laughing but
that's still not the end of all of this
will these guys be expected to sing at
your wedding like I said I can't afford
them oh yeah you're really okay no I
mean look they have to they have a lot
of work to do you know while I'm out
getting married again I see I said this
is at the end of the day it is Katie's
wedding and she can invite who she wants
and despite the guest list she did say
she's actually a pretty chill
bride-to-be but you know what it's so
funny it's like I'm I'm actually like a
not a bridezilla
I call myself like the viola okay I'm
kind of chill but I am one of those
girls where I got engaged for every 14th
and then I I booked the place February
19th oh did all you wasted no time oh
yes
sadly Katie and Orlando won't be
spending their Valentine's engagement
anniversary together but what I love too
is Valentine's Day weekend premiere
people can snuggle up I gotta ask you
guys what are your plans what are you
doing for me then I'm having a gallon
time
because Orlando is still in Prague I'm
not gonna be sitting still right at the
big putting the plate on the table
watching the show I'm chilling would you
throw a mean galantine oh no I throw a
lot of great things but you know this is
it's a homework holiday
I loved 365 actually 366 days this year
all year round last fall a source told
ET that Katie and Orlando we're looking
to throw a fall 2020 wedding and while
it doesn't seem her fellow American Idol
judges will make the guest list
someone surprising put at the time our
source said quote they've already talked
guest list and have even talked about
including Taylor Swift OMG yeah from
enemies to potential wedding guests we
love to see it
[Music]
alright guys that's it for today for all
the latest on Katy Perry's wedding
planning adventures stick with ET until
next time I'm Katie Krauss and bye for
now
[Music]